I also want to say that we reached a
milestone on our podcast we reached how
much half a million half a million
downloads in a month which is amazing
for us we're over a little over a year
in and the fans and the people are dead
you spent they have been amazing and I
we want to thank you because um things
haven't been going well in my my private
life and now my private life my well my
privileged my career live are you Patti
are you proud of your work well I want
to say this is that because Chris D'Elia
is obviously the star of it and I had
saw I saw a rough cut of it that's a
half of it or whatever I just feel weird
because I'm dancing and you know and I
know what I look at my face I go I know
what I was thinking at the time but you
know it cooked together pretty good and
pretty much everyone likes it except for
one person and the one person happens to
be my girlfriend she doesn't like it she
thought it was cheesy right words in my
mouth what how'd you feel about the
video and be real I nothing against all
the talents that are in the video or
nothing against anybody at all
individually you Fahim D'Elia probably
the funniest people I have ever met in
my life but as a video it was
cringe-worthy for me
AJ McLean a Backstreet Boy was randomly
dancing
AJ McLean he's a nice guy I know I'm
sure I don't know I'm not speaking to
anybody's character all it is about AJ
McCoy is uncomfortable watching when I
saw him on the video shoot by the way
what some of you comic he goes no I used
to be in a boy band I go what's a call
he goes back Street right
actually boys oh yeah that's good
anything about it I don't know anything
about it I've heard of the Backstreet
Boys but I don't know who's in it yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then but he was so
nice you know you know it's like if I'm
at a club and people don't know who I am
in a stand-up comedy club I get a little
offended a little bit like oh you do do
you do comedy yeah you know I want to go
yeah I'm a regular here or whatever but
he was very like you know cool about it
and you know I don't know anything about
him so I have no opinion one way or the
other I'm not to me he's cool I'm sure
he's everyone is fantastic yeah everyone
involved was great that's not my point
my point was you asked me my honest
opinion about it and that's not true I
love both of you guys I love both of you
guys so much yeah
hi you see the video I saw clip yeah do
you not like it
no it's comedy there's a bunch of girls
there's three comics that Kris dancing
like a weirdo that's the whole point
right yeah yeah it's funny Kris dancing
made me laugh uh-huh
I will say that you don't laugh at
Bobby's face but he's kind of just like
no I wanted to say it review how do I
grow as a dancer hey I want to I want to
I don't have doubt in your dancing
skills yeah you are a phenom on a dance
floor
thank you it's just the I just found it
to be a little like cheesy
yeah like under it you know like you
guys collectively are one of our comedy
gold and I just thought that it was like
wasted on a video with just dancing and
girls like any other hip-hop video mmm
collectively you should I don't know
whatever I'm done
don't make me the bad person here I'm
proud of you for being in a Flo Rida
video thank you that's all that's all
you can say all you have to say don't
ask for me and I was / again I also was
trending last week trying did it why is
it for the hot one yes
that was [ __ ] funny hilarious
captain that was fun yes did you really
[ __ ] your pants yeah do you ever doubt
that he shits his pants I do it all the
time he does it every day she looks so
hot the last one yeah and I don't really
I was really angry during that shoot and
it was I was in a lot of pain but in
retrospect I saw the little clips of it
I enjoyed it I guess and so thank you
for um thank you for watching it
whoever's listening that was a really
bad I like that was funny thank you
thank you so much hilarious
[Music]